the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi there's a cute book called the point
and the line that was also made into an
animated cartoon that ends with the line
to the vector belongs the spoils and in
this particular course we're going to
find that both the traditional meaning
of vector plus a modern meaning of
vector plays a very fundamental role in
the study of calculus of several
variables in fact the modern definition
which we will ultimately get to later in
the course is the one that will be of
utmost importance to us but in the mean
time to better appreciate what this will
be like we will start with a more
conventional treatment of vectors
hopefully one fringe benefit of this
will be to revisit what vectors really
are and to get on with this let me again
point out that we will be giving an
overview of what the unit is all about
in this lecture and the details will
again be left to the supplementary notes
the text and the exercises I call this
lecture arrow arithmetic and the reason
for calling this arrow arithmetic
hopefully will become clear in a moment
for the time being let's very quickly
review what a vector is I think most of
us know this but just to make sure there
are no misinterpretations a vector is
any quantity which depends on a
direction as well as a magnitude in
other words a vector quantity is 1 which
in order to specify uniquely we must
tell what its magnitude is its size we
must tell what direction it's in and
finally something which I call the sense
wherein I distinguish between the same
direction being traversed in two
different ways and perhaps the best way
to emphasize this is in terms of a
one-dimensional analogy that we have
already studied very very early in our
mathematical careers
I'm thinking of the idea of visualizing
sine numbers in terms of the number line
in other words recall that the number
line was essentially the x-axis and
starting at some origin which we call
say zero we numbered 1 2 etc if we moved
in the right the left to right direction
and negative 1 and negative 2 etc if we
went from right to left in other words
even though the direction of the x axis
is still the same whether we go from
left to right or from right to left we
distinguish between the two motions in
terms of what and this is what we mean
by the sense of a vector some people say
well the direction includes the sense I
prefer to have these two words dangling
around so I can put them at my disposal
in any way that I see fit but roughly
speaking then this is all a vector is
now the idea is why arrows and the
answer is and here's a little ratio I
put down here an arrow is 2 a vector as
a length is 2 a scaler where by scaler I
mean a number something which has a
magnitude but no direction remember when
we first started talking about numerical
arithmetic and talked about graphing and
visualizing numbers as lengths we pick
the length to represent the number and
at that particular time since there was
only one degree of freedom namely the
x-axis we didn't emphasize direction but
the idea is to carry this analogy
further what one does is when one has a
quantity which is a vector an arrow a
traditional arrow a directed line
segment with a given sense the arrow
head indicating the sense is perhaps the
best way of drawing what we mean by a
vector namely I have just a few random
examples here here's a collection of
things which are arrows hey they're line
segments in a given direction and the
arrowhead indicates a particular sense
notice by the way that the concept of a
does not depend on an arrow anymore than
the concept of a number depends on a
length the arrow is simply a convenient
geometric representation for visualizing
the vector okay now hopefully in terms
of the last unit you now have the
feeling that in mathematics to have an
arithmetic one needs more than a
collection of objects that to have a
structure one needs a collection of
objects together with certain rules and
definitions and what-have-you and
consequently it becomes rather mandatory
that somehow or other we be able to
categorize a pair of vectors as to
whether they shall be called equal or
not see what do we mean by even saying
that two vectors shall be equal to
equality of vectors and I claim the
following and let me just State this
cold-bloodedly until we come to the end
and show what we're driving at again to
say that the vector a equals the vector
B means that first of all the magnitude
of a equals the magnitude of B by the
way again as in the one-dimensional case
when we call the absolute value the
length we do the same thing in terms of
arrows we abbreviate the magnitude of an
arrow by writing the absolute value of
the arrow in other words the absolute
value of a must equal the absolute value
of B secondly the arrow a must be
parallel to the arrow B and thirdly a
and B must have the same sense and again
to show you what this is remember I said
to you a moment ago that the arrows are
just a convenient pictorial way of
representing a vector let's observe that
these three properties here
juxtaposition very nicely with these
three properties here in other words
notice that our definition of equality
of arrows captures exactly what three
ingredients go into defining a vector
since all we're talking about is
magnitude direction and sense how can we
distinguish validly between two vectors
other than in
terms of magnitude direction and sense
okay well by the way let's be very
careful about this you see as long as
the only way that we can determine the
difference between two vectors are
arrows is in terms of their magnitude
direction and sense what this means is
that if you have two vectors which are
parallel have the same length two arrows
same length same direction and the same
sense they must be called equal you see
in other words vectors do not have to
coincide to be equal unlike the case of
straight lines in other words if I were
to draw a pair of parallel lines here of
equal length these would be called
different lines as soon as I do this
these are called equal arrows why
because of our definition of equality
and if somebody says I don't like that
definition well this is the same as the
rule that three strikes is an out in
baseball if somebody doesn't like that
rule you said it won't look it go and
play your own game and make as many
strikes as and out as you want but don't
call that game baseball because that
will confuse it with the game that we're
playing here which is different in other
words we make up our rules to govern as
I said in the last lecture what we
believe to be reality and we believe
that for how we're going to use vectors
this is a very very natural definition
and this is not the first time in
mathematics that we've done something
like this way back around the third or
fourth grade is a little analogy you get
used to saying one half equals three six
but obviously the ordered number pair 1
comma 2 and 3 comma 6 look different it
certainly makes a difference physically
whether you cut a pie in half and take
one piece or cut the pie into six pieces
and take three of them the physical
process is different the two fractions
don't look alike why do we call them
equal and it means that in terms of what
we want ratios to mean the number which
you must multiply by two to get one is
the same number that you must multiply
by 6 to get 3 and consequently let's
just keep the Equality in that sense who
cares where they look alike or not
let's call them equal if they capture
the important characteristic and that's
the way this game is going to be played
all the time we will make up our
definitions to fit our mood and
hopefully the mood that suits me best
will suit you best because I will try to
pick the reasons that you yourselves
would have liked to have seen motivate
why we did the things that we did or
that we're going to do here so let me
talk about the addition of vectors and
let me put the word addition in
quotation marks here to indicate that
all I mean by the addition of vectors
and perhaps I should still say addition
of arrows is I would like a rule that
tells me how to combine two arrows to
form another arrow now again I can make
up hundreds of rules that tell me how
for two given arrows I'm going to form a
third arrow from the given two but since
our aim is to solve problems of the real
world why not pick a definition why not
pick a definition that has already been
used in physics and in other
applications the thing called the result
of for example given a point O and two
forces represented as arrows a and B
acting at O we have agreed or you may
recall that the resultant force is the
vector that forms the diagonal of the
parallelogram which has a and B as
consecutive edges in other words this
vector here was what in the old days was
called the resultant because that has
such a nice usage I am going to call
that the sum of two vectors okay
by the sum of two vectors I mean what
physically used to be the resultant and
a very nice way of remembering the rule
is remember that this vector B is equal
to this vector because this is a
parallelogram these are equal in
magnitude parallel in direction and have
the same sense notice that if I wanted a
quick recipe that was convenient for
adding two vectors a and B you say what
place the tail of the second next to the
head of the first and then draw the
vector the arrow that goes from the tail
of the first
to the head of the second and this would
be the definition of the addition of
arrows and again this is done in much
more detail in our written material by
the way notice again a parallelism
between the structure of vectors and the
structure of ordinary arithmetic in the
same way that given two numbers they
have one sum but they given some can be
formed by different combinations of
numbers that two given vectors which I
call here x1 and y1 give a as a sum but
notice also that the vector a is the sum
of the vectors x2 and y2 in other words
in fact to generalize this if I picked
any point I wanted on the blackboard
here and drew any two lines one going
from the tail of a to this point and one
going from this point to the head of a
notice that the resulting two vectors
here this vector Plus this vector by
definition of vector addition head to
tail from the tail of the first to the
head of the second would still be the
vector a in other words in terms of the
diagram that I drew originally notice
that a can be written as x1 plus y1 it
can also be written as x2 plus y2 and
notice again the similarity of the
structure between arithmetic and vectors
and notice the arbitrariness with which
we make up our definitions you see we
make up the definitions to be our
servant rather than for us to become the
servant of the subject we model the
definitions the truth that we call after
what we believe happens in real life by
the way a very convenient coordinate
system is our old friend the X&Y
Cartesian coordinate system and the
reason for this is as follows given any
vector a we can always assume that the
vector originates at the origin and the
reason for that is we have already seen
that two vectors are equal if they have
the same magnitude
direction and sense so wherever a was in
the plane of the blackboard we can shift
it parallel to itself so this tail
starts at the origin let's assume that
the vector a the arrow a which starts at
the origin terminates at the point a
comma B let AI be a unit vector meaning
a vector that has one unit of length in
the direction of the positive x-axis let
J be a unit vector which is in the
direction of a positive Y axis and our
claim is that our definition of addition
and you've all seen this I'm pretty sure
before is that the vector a can now be
written as what that a is equal to a I
plus B J where you see if you've seen
this notation before notice that in
terms of our game we are now forced to
introduce a new operation because we
claimed in that game that its validity
that's important validity not truth in
other words if all I can use are the
rules of my game for the first time what
do I see here I see a number multiplying
the vector and if I don't have rules of
my game that tell me what a number
multiplied by a vector means in terms of
the logic machine the logic machine
can't do a thing to give me inescapable
conclusions without assumptions without
rules there can be no proof so I must
make up a new definition and this
definition is called scalar
multiplication and it's going to tell me
how to multiply a scalar a number by a
vector if C is a number and V is a
vector by C times V I mean a vector
which has has to be careful here C C
could be a negative number and since you
think of length as being positive I take
the absolute value of C just to get the
magnitude of the number in here you see
in other words this is a vector which
has the magnitude of C times the magnet
is the magnitude of C times the
magnitude of V meaning it's C times as
large as V if C is positive and minus C
times as large as V if C is negative the
same meaning of absolute value as always
for example two times V would be a
vector whose
magnitude was twice that of the vector V
negative two times V would also be a
vector whose magnitude is twice that of
V the other property is what I've just
told the magnitude I also have to give
you the direction and the sense C times
V is in the same direction as V in other
words minus two times V and plus two
times V both have the direction of V and
both are what twice the magnitude of V
the only difference between the minus is
this that C times V has the same sense
same sense as what same sense as V if C
is positive that means if C is negative
it has the opposite sense in other words
for example twice V two times V has the
same sense as V minus 2 V has the
opposite sense of V but the important
point is this that vector arithmetic
shares many structural properties of
regular arithmetic that is very crucial
to understand you know I have a friend
of mine who doesn't like teaching
students who are having a few problems
with ordinary arithmetic and likes to
teach advanced courses and he often has
said at a trouble with the average high
school curriculum for the average
student is that by the time the student
is through he knows three things if you
see a sign change it if you see a
decimal point move it and if you see a
fraction inverted but he should have
gone one step further when the average
old-time engineering student Sahra
vector he only knew one thing about it
and the one thing that he knew about it
was if you see a vector break it down
into components and after that that was
the end of what he ever did with vectors
in the old days but the thing that is
crucial to understand here is that we
will use vector arithmetic in a far more
powerful way we will use the structure
of vector arithmetic in the same way
that we formed algebra from numerical
arithmetic we will form vector algebra
and vector calculus from vector
arithmetic let me give you an example we
already know that for two numbers a and
B a plus B equals B plus a
my claim is that from our definition of
arrows and the like it should also be a
rule that four arrows a plus B should
equal B plus a or four numbers we
already know that a plus B plus C equals
a plus B plus C that doesn't look right
that by the way what I wrote there
wasn't false
it was certainly true but it was too
trivially true I guess what I wanted to
emphasize here was the voice inflection
made no difference now again notice how
we verify the rules of the game see I
have to make up rules that I will call
basic truths those rules are axioms will
be modeled after what I believe to be
true in reality now notice that in
reality I form this whole idea in terms
of what arrows I define what addition
meant let's take a look and see what a
plus B means if this is the vector a and
this is the vector B then what is the
vector a plus B by definition of how you
add two vectors this vector here would
be a plus B okay on the other hand I
could take the vector a which is down
here move it parallel to itself so it
originates here mark it off the same
length this is still the vector a if I
now draw the arrow that goes from the
tail of B to the head of a what vector
is this well by definition its B plus a
power B plus a and a plus B related they
are opposite sides of a parallelogram
therefore they have the same magnitude
and same direction and the picture shows
us that they have the same sense since
this is true in the picture why not
claim that one of the rules of our game
of vector arithmetic
even though legally you shouldn't use
pictures but pictures do give us the
motivation why not say okay we'll accept
the rule that a plus B equals B plus a
how about our second rule over here
let's take three vectors let me take a
over here
let me put B over here and let me put
say C over here and I hope that this
will come out legible enough for all of
us to see I claim on the one hand that I
can think of a plus B plus C in two
different ways in other words to use the
way that says a plus B plus C from this
diagram how do I get the vector B plus C
since B and C are lined up in the right
position head to tail the vector B plus
C is the one that goes from the tail of
B to the head of C so I call this vector
B plus C now what is a plus B plus C
it's this vector plus this one in other
words this vector here could be labeled
a plus B plus C on the other hand what
is the vector A plus B a plus B is this
vector because it goes from the tail of
a to the head of B and consequently a
plus B plus C is the vector that goes
from the tail of a plus B to the head of
C in other words what vector is that
it's this vector but what name does that
have we just saw that's a plus B plus C
and now we see what we have two
different names for the same arrow in
particular then these two different
names represent what two arrows which
have the same magnitude sense and
direction and therefore they're equal
and that's why we make up rules like
this and by the way the analogy
continues on and this is done in much
more detail in our notes but I just
thought I would like to say a few more
words in general for example one talks
about the zero vector and I write that
with a zero with an arrow over it to
indicate the zero arrow maybe your
intuition tells you that the zero vector
should somehow be connected with a zero
number but the point that I want to
drive at is an analogy to what we did in
the preview
lecture when we showed YB to the 0 has
to be defined to be one the idea is that
in ordinary arithmetic what is the
beauty of the number zero the beauty of
the number zero is that with respect to
addition it does not change the identity
of any number that any number plus zero
is that number back again in particular
then why not keep the same structure for
vectors and it's our choice to make we
like to say ok let's define the zero
vector to be such that if a is any other
vector a plus zero will still be a well
let's get an idea of what that means let
B denote the magnitude of the zero
vector what this means is what how do I
add 0 to a I start with the vector a and
it originates here and terminates at the
point P now how do I add on the zero
vector the zero vector all I know is
it's going to start at P and B lengths
being so the surest thing I can say is
look at let me draw a circle centered at
P with radius equal to B in other words
the radius of this circle here the
radius of this circle is big all I know
is that whatever the zero vector is if
its magnitude is be the zero vector must
originate at P and terminate someplace
on this circle because that's the locus
of all vectors of length B which
originated P for the sake of argument
let's say that the zero vector happens
to be PQ then a plus zero is the vector
that goes from this point to Q but a
plus zero must be a and since a and a
plus zero originate at the same point
the only way they can have the same
magnitude direction and sense is that
they must coincide in other words in
particular P must equal Q and as soon as
P equals Q the magnitude of the zero
vector must be the number zero in other
words in terms of our game structure
again if we want this structural rule to
be obeyed and again I must emphasize
this the choice is asked to make but if
we want the structural rule to be obeyed
we must define the zero vector to be the
vector which has zero magnitude as
natural as it seems that's not the real
reason for doing it we do it because it
gives us the structure that we want the
same is true for example about the
additive inverse
remember in ordinary arithmetic the
additive inverse meant what the number
that must be added to the given number
to give the zero number or the number
zero in vectors we should define
negative a to be the vector which when
added to a gives the zero vector well
look at any vector that I add to a let
me call that vector B any vector that I
add to a which I call a plus B looks
like this well what is the only way that
the vector a plus B can be the zero
vector
well the zero vector has no length that
means the only way that's possible is if
the tail of a plus B coincides with the
head of a plus B and the only way that
can happen is if B terminates right here
in other words the vector that we call
negative a is going to be the vector
which has the same magnitude and
direction is a but the opposite sense
and we're not saying it's self-evident
always saying is look if you want this
structural property to be true you have
no choice but to define negative a to be
the vector which has the same magnitude
and direction is a but the opposite
sense and by the way as soon as you do
that there are no more guessing games
involved in how you subtract two vectors
for just in the same way that we did it
in ordinary arithmetic we define the
difference of two vectors a minus B to
mean the vector a added to the vector
negative B and what is negative B the
vector which just has the opposite sense
of the vector B and again these
computational details are left to the
notes and to the exercises but the main
overview is I want you to get from this
lecture is to see that there
more two vectors than dividing them up
into components that there is an
arithmetic imposed on them and that
arithmetic that's imposed on vectors is
just as real as the arithmetic of the
ordinary real numbers and to reinforce
this in our next lesson we will talk
about vectors in three-dimensional space
where the geometry becomes tougher but
the structure remains exactly the same
but until next time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate